I as you've probably heard me say a
million times I love this franchise yeah
yeah it's great love I want to stress
that right um so I just have to ask
you've done so many roles and you've
you've had such a great career what does
it mean to you to be part of the John
Wick franchise it's beautiful to be a
part of this I mean with this one in
particular the Bowery King gets to set
the table
for the audience and it's like I'm gonna
take you on a ride and it's going to be
the ride of your life
so I'm just I'm grateful that I actually
got to be in this one one of the things
about this movie which I don't think the
average person is going to realize
there's an action set piece in Berlin
where Keanu is fighting with tons of
extras in the scene can you sort of
explain to people like why most movies
don't have like a hundred extras behind
them in like a huge fight sequence
because it's it's crazy it's
logistically almost impossible to sort
of control that kind of a situation
where you have hundreds of background
artists and then you're you know you're
a central character moving in and around
all of that that's it requires a lot of
patience to sort of
move all of those pieces
in a in an orderly fashion without
people getting hurt it's hard what do
you think would surprise fans of the
John Wick franchise to learn about the
actual making of the films when you're
on set
um the thing that always
that I always forget when I haven't done
a movie in a while
that I'm you know subtly reminded of
when you walk on a set is just how
painstakingly tedious it is to get
everything ready just before you roll
the camera it takes
days
weeks months for everything to actually
be where it should be and for everything
to be working
um
for a director to say action and then
what happens between action and cut
you know it seems like it's magic it's
not
some of it's magic but a lot of it is
preparation the movies have to me some
of the best action scenes of the last
few years yeah do you have one of them
that you still can't believe was in one
of these films is that basically do you
have a favorite oh oh there's two
sequences in this particular chapter of
WIC
that are unbelievable so everything that
happens in Paris is completely off the
chain
um
and uh
and all of keanu's Judo in this movie is
totally next level
um I completely agree
early in your career you worked with
someone named Francis Ford Copeland and
I believe you've worked with him again
recently in his Mega project yeah just
finished yeah um Adam Driver said he
wrapped two nights ago yeah um and I'm
just curious uh what can you tease about
your role and what because I'm so
looking forward to this movie and I'm
just curious what you can say what it's
been like making it uh it's been a joy
to work with Francis again it's been a
privilege to work with him again I
wouldn't have the kind of career that I
have without Francis Coppola
uh he's been talking about this movie
since I was a child
and
um I was like yes sir I'll be there what
do you need
and so I went and the character I play
is sort of uh a confidant to Adam Driver
as a character called Caesar I won't
pressure you anymore except to say I I
really cannot wait to see this I'm so
happy he made it anything for it himself
exactly it's it's he's making history
yeah 100 on that note congrats on this
movie thank you and I wish you nothing
but the best same to you brother